hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 19 2017 what's going on how
you doing how are you what's up ah
that's great yes you're doing good
are you doing good that's good I'm doing
great I'm actually recording this on
Sunday June 18th 49 years old my first
[ __ ] birthday first Father's Day oh
geez bill what did you do god bless you
you're in the clubhouse [ __ ] turn you
finally became a dad what did you do
I had a great day I ate a great day you
know they go all out
for Mother's Day it's just brunch after
brunch after this after that I went over
to a car show over on Rodeo Drive Rodeo
Drive right there below were they rode
where they will drive the fancy schmancy
place evidently they have a father
station car show every father's day
officer if if they're going to call it
Father's Day car show yes they've had it
every year and of course I never went I
was never a dead I never even heard
about the [ __ ] thing so I was not on
the email list you know Billy the Kid
list is you guys called me back in the
day as of five months ago you could
still call me that so I was never on the
email list and goddamn and I was like
I'm going over there
so we head over there and you know it's
like you know the beautiful people how
the beautiful people and me that rich
rich ass [ __ ] yeah Beverly Hills they
called the Beverly Hills car show and I
got to tell you man it's [ __ ]
beautiful cars I wasn't going to go to
the Petersen museum I was going to do
that I figure I can go to the Petersen
Museum any time this is the father's day
one I got to go to that one then I'll do
the Petersen later right so I [ __ ] go
over there Petersen Museum by the way
right down next to that place that's
right where big he got shot
Wilshire in [ __ ] Fairfax so anyways
so I'm over there Rodale drive I'm
checking it out right there's all these
rich people you know there's all these
beautiful [ __ ] you know I don't know
what you know walking around god knows
how old they are they're really getting
good with the plastic surgery man
they're really really getting [ __ ] it
was there with some amazing old looking
women walking around you know we're
forever 21 [ __ ] that they bought it you
know I don't know one of those stores up
and down the block right so we're
walking around you know it's [ __ ]
hilarious every restaurant was like
closed over there like [ __ ] the dads
they're like five food trucks even over
there I'm like a sit daddy doesn't give
a [ __ ] show him a couple of [ __ ]
Batmobile show them the Lincoln from
Entourage which they had over there
which was [ __ ] cool [ __ ] one of the
great cars out there the Lincoln melt
suicide doors and all that not a
convertible guy but you know it worked
for the show the overhead shot iconic
shot at this point they had the Eleanor
car from gone in 60 seconds but I liked
I liked I always liked the weird [ __ ] I
saw like a 19 what the [ __ ] was like a
1961 62 or 63 mercedes-benz limousine
and out of everything that was there
there was a Tucker there there was a
[ __ ] one of those mid feel like a 55
Mercedes gullwing you know a bunch of
Ferraris Lamborghinis you know that was
those weird years in the 70s those ones
uh Adam Corolla has a lot of them I
don't mean weird like they're not
good-looking it's just like you know I
always saw mr. racing car and then to me
it was for me I just felt it went right
to magnum p.i it was until I did
Corollas podcast back in the day when I
saw the lamb burgers and fries I was
just like one of these he's like oh this
is that this one this is that one from
like the like the late 67 now they're
cool as [ __ ] he was ahead of the curve
by the way I was watching a local
newscast out here and Adam Carissa free
plug here Adam Corolla was on
and he was promoting he's got a he's got
a documentary on the 24 Hours of LeMans
in the 1950s when Ford decided that they
were going to guess compete and see what
they could do over there and they came
out with the Ford GT he's got this great
skin getting rave reviews and he has
another documentary that he already put
out about the racing life of Paul Newman
and if you go to his website I believe
it's chassis comm something if you just
put an Adam Corolla LeMans it's going to
come up and what I love is all I could
find on the website was just a DVD which
is great for me as an old man I don't
like that [ __ ] hey you download it
and then it's in the air and somehow
it's on my computer and then I dump some
orange juice on the keyboard then I
don't own it anymore
I like the DVD I'm an old man I like the
DVD that's like having the gold behind
you money so had I known about this I
would have asked for both of those for
Father's Day so instead I'm just going
to buy myself honey so anyways I [ __ ]
go over there and they got this
mercedes-benz like 1961 62 63 some in
the early 60s and it's a it's a
limousine
it's [ __ ] black it's got this I took
a video I know I always say I'm gonna
post it then I was forget that I say I'm
going to do it but I'm gonna try to
remember here had this beautiful red
interior and it was just I was like that
that right there that's what the [ __ ]
isn't the older I get as much as I enjoy
driving I don't enjoy driving in LA
because the traffic is just [ __ ]
insane and my wife my class she overs
all the time so I'm getting used to this
jumping in a car and somebody else is
driving you know want to go out with her
and I get all this business done be it
breaking people's balls back on some
text you know calling back [ __ ] Joe
DeRosa or some [ __ ] that it calls solves
Joe DeRosa for your consideration is the
[ __ ] veterinarian on that wonderful
show turn email calls business [ __ ] all
of that
and you know you always read about these
these [ __ ] people out here these
moguls like the Ryan Seacrest's out here
they they don't [ __ ] drive they have
a driver they sit in the back and they
get [ __ ] done they pull the curtain
right and they just back there they got
like the Janet Jackson headset on
they're [ __ ] firing off emails bit
buying stocks I don't know what they're
doing back there I'm not a mogul it's
like they're going to tell you [ __ ]
tell someone I'd be a mogul and
everybody's a mogul then what you use
over here just a regular guy next thing
you know you stopping at a red light you
looking over you look is that Ryan
Seacrest driving his own [ __ ] car
what happened
thought this guy had 17 [ __ ] TV shows
anyways I I could really get into that
to be honest with you who's kidding who
I'm not a mobile as I'm just [ __ ]
lazy
and I don't know I think there's just
two types of people as they get older
this is the person that just you know
takes up cycling in rock climbing and
they take like a [ __ ] glassblowing
class of some [ __ ] you know and then
there's other people being like you know
what I [ __ ] tired man you know I like
to chill if I get another 49 years or
whatever I get you know I'm on the back
nine who's kidding who 49 times to 98 I
want to make a hundred stay in pausable
who's kidding - all right so them on the
12th holes
[Laughter]
biggest [ __ ] wants to drive in LA it's
[ __ ] horrible
I would actually thoroughly enjoy and I
would just finish you if you had that
kind of loop you redo an old [ __ ]
beautiful car like that you restore it
you bring it back to life and then you
just in the back you know you got you
got you know you got a little humidor
[ __ ] cigars you know a couple of your
favorite little [ __ ] accoutrements
being the booze there then you just
[ __ ] whatever you drive around
well whatever your driver's name is you
still call him James
every [ __ ] every chauffeur was always
named that would that be great you want
to go to the movies you know I drink too
much already man there's no way I could
handle always having a designated driver
I began [ __ ] steward going to the
supermarket
speaking of which Billy no fun oh Jesus
Jesus Christ for seven days in seven
[ __ ] days and last night I had a
couple glasses of wine we went out with
another couple what am I supposed to do
everybody you know I'm having an Italian
meal not suppose to have a little Barolo
come on come on what am I supposed to
hit a couple of those you know and I
don't even [ __ ] like mine it just
it's just it's always reminding you of
the hangover it's going to give you
turns your teeth gray but I actually
enjoyed that's the one wine that I like
I really enjoyed it last night and I was
actually going to order a whiskey but I
almost said the referee the waiter
forgot to come back and ask me at that
point it's just like [ __ ] this I'm just
going to stay with the wine and then
tonight my family took me out for
Father's Day and I had one whiskey I
called man I got a [ __ ] good one
right I got a really good 28 years old
and then I went outside to return a
phone call and I'd set the glass down I
came back and one of my red letters had
bumped the table and said they knocked a
little bit out and I didn't think there
was that much and then I looked down
there was this big puddle of it I was
like ah [ __ ] that was 28 years old in
the back of my head I was like ah that's
good because I'm trying not to drink
anyways but it was 28 years old this
[ __ ] poured in a glass I sipped it and
then somebody came by hit the table and
there was a puddle of it spent 20 years
in a [ __ ] barrel to be spilt on the
floor and then cleaned up with a rag oh
that's a travesty I felt my liver crying
but it was good because then I had the
perfect amount of booze and I was fine
so I don't know I know you guys who were
in a a you know collecting your little
chippy booze there
you knew it just five days
/ you know give you a little cookie got
you down there che there's no way even
if I was like a full-on [ __ ] alky
like I'm in triple-a of alcoholism I
never got called up to the big show
basically like Kevin Costner in Bull
Durham except I'm drinking that would
annoy me going to AAA and they'd give me
my stupid chip like that's what I'm like
I'm supposed to be [ __ ] chasing these
things I got too much of a contrarian in
me
that's the new word for constant by the
way yeah a bit of a canary canary a
contrarian a bit of a contrarian yeah
yeah you're you difficult you're a [ __ ]
you know you're [ __ ] pain in the ass
you're the kind of guy if the [ __ ]
jet went down you're the [ __ ] guy
you're the guy that would get us killed
we'd all be [ __ ] sitting there if we
survived going there you know let's say
we go over this Ridge everybody
agreement yeah and always well one good
simple - rich why are you [ __ ] go
over there buddy
we'd mauled by a bobcat we'll wait for
you to slowly die and then and it is a
new nourishment for the rest of this
[ __ ] walked down the snowy
godforsaken Tundra anyway sorry um the
[ __ ] of my time yeah so we go to the car
show right none of the [ __ ]
restaurants are open [ __ ] the dad's
there's like food trucks nobody kids you
know it's funny though I didn't give a
[ __ ]
my wife was upset oh my god why we none
of these places are opened
she's like eh you are right what does OK
I don't give a sh I don't give a [ __ ]
you know I really don't I am I am I'm
wired like a guy I walked around I
looked at some shiny cars I'm happy it's
hot as [ __ ] let's get back in the car
and go home I'm fine completely fine
brunch that's that's um you [ __ ] turning
this whole [ __ ] thing to do a whole
day yeah Father's Day you leave it I had
to buy the perfect Father's Day and then
I'm saying I started my day
[ __ ] uh no fun Billy I could wake up
now like super early and I finally have
a little drum space about twenty ways a
little uh little Jesus Christ I came to
talk a little ways away from like 20
minutes away from my house I got a
little rehearsal studio right he can
just rent them I got the smallest
[ __ ] one like if I stretch out I can
touch the walls on all sides and I got
this little [ __ ] that little sonar
kit that I bought the martini kit 16
inch based bass drum which cracks me up
because I was playing that giant bottom
one that had a 26 inch [ __ ] bass drum
and I'm trying to you know just go in a
completely different different direction
after all of these goddamn years of just
[ __ ] trying to ape everything that uh
that he did and I just hit me one [ __ ]
day I told you what if one day I just
sat there and said what if this [ __ ]
guy came back to life and he came
walking into my house I keep saying this
on the podcast right and I was just like
hey man John Bonham holy [ __ ] hey I'm a
big fan of yours come in and look at my
drum kit I had his exact drum kit right
down to the Rogers hi-hat he would have
looked at he would have slowly back out
of the [ __ ] room and what was funny
is now I'm going down this whole [ __ ]
rabbit hole
you know I'm listening to Pantera and
[ __ ] Primus and Miles Davis figure
that one out listening to all of his
[ __ ] great drummers from Philly Joe
Tony Williams to [ __ ] Jack Dee's and
I just listen to these [ __ ] geniuses
and trying to get something else in my
[ __ ] head and so reading up on Tony
Williams I went down this [ __ ] rabbit
hole full of I don't know how many hours
on the Internet
just trying to fill these tracks I was
listening to him trying to see if I
could there's so many tracks where Tony
is just killing it live and they just
won't show them it's so [ __ ] annoying
though we showing miles of Coltrane a
[ __ ] neck cold eating plain Coltrane
Miles our [ __ ] was it short
he played with I don't know if they're
always showing those guys yes it's like
if everybody else stops playing they'll
finally [ __ ] show him it's annoying
but you know typical they never show the
drummer that's why I love the romantics
when I was a kid and what I liked a boat
you came out I finally got the drummer
was singing if the drummer sang then
they would be on Hotel California with
Don Henley you'd see the drummer the
whole [ __ ] time other than that you
were [ __ ] out of luck so anyways I ended
up when you read about Tony that leads
to Billy Cobham which leads to [ __ ]
eventually you know I don't know Vinnie
Colaiuta and Steve Smith and all these
[ __ ] guys and then they start talking
about the guys they listen to and then
you go back around again it's amazing so
I end up finding this quote that really
made me feel good about getting rid of
the drum kit that I did because
sometimes I think DOM and I always
wanted that kid I finally [ __ ] had it
and then I just always think yeah you
sat down and plated you sounded like you
so it was too [ __ ] big for you and
you have all these other ideas why don't
you go pursue those and I just stumbled
on this quote by Vinnie Colaiuta right
that's actually transcends playing drums
you can apply this to anything it's he
says this is when he was trying to find
his own style he said I went through
periods where I tried to imitate Tony
and Billy that's tony williams a billy
cobham
because I eventually realized how
dangerous it was basically trying to
imitate those guys that goes I began to
ask myself what am i saying I wasn't
saying anything it had been said before
and had a reason for being said but I
didn't have a reason I wasn't making a
statement I was just repeating it like a
parrot by imitating and copying someone
else a person becomes a parrot
I saw the trap and I knew as great as
those guys were and still are that I had
to find my own voice and I was like god
dammit look at that that applies to
stand-up comedy that applies to [ __ ]
washing cars do you want to be one of
the greats you know how many times can
you watch mr. Miyagi do the wax on wax
off before you're going to [ __ ] break
out of it come up with a new way to do
it right
I don't know [ __ ] to tell you I'm just
happy so now I got this place so I wake
up now because you know the way my
daughter sleeps she sleeps in these
four-hour chunks so she finally falls
asleep you know around 2:00 in the
morning after she slept from like you
know eight to 12 then she'd be like up
like an hour and a half or some [ __ ] and
then she sleeps till like 7:00
my wife feeds her and then she goes back
to sleep again until 10:00 so that
window right there from 7:00 to 10:00
now I just been jumping in the car drive
20 minutes down the street nobody's up
there's no musicians over at that place
you know they're just getting done doing
blow they're going home you know I'm
there like 8:00 in the [ __ ] morning
and I get to play for like a nice solid
hour having the time of my [ __ ] life
I don't know why I didn't do this for
myself years ago I hadn't never dawned
on me to do it I was always trying to
play min the [ __ ] house and trying to
find quiet ways to do it because whose
kid knew drums are [ __ ] annoying
others unless you're the person playing
them so I finally got this place and I'm
be on psych so we'll see we'll see what
this little kit leaves me but uh I know
whatever I'm just saying was a great
father's day so I went out tonight and
then got a nice frame picture of me
holding my beautiful daughter and I
could not be having my arms around her
anymore and she looks content as hell it
was an instant classic I'm kissing her
on the cheek and I got it framed I'm
looking at right now sitting on my desk
and [ __ ] sites so happy Father's Day
Father's Day to all the fathers out
there you know and if you used to play
drums you want to play them again go get
one of those get that [ __ ] that
Questlove little break beat set go find
some [ __ ] studio space country like
125 200 bucks a month who gives up [ __ ]
you know go get it go down there bring
your [ __ ] you know or find a studio
space like you know where I used to play
I never used to say that excited when
anybody bugged me down there the best
place that I found out here in LA if you
don't have time to get a drum kit and
all that [ __ ] but if you just want to go
play some play
is cascade studios down on Santa Monica
app just east of Highland it's the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] clean the drum kits are
great and it was the first class place
and I went to a bunch of places that was
the best place that I found so free plug
there it's speaking of that speaking and
oh by the way everybody keeps telling me
to watch the [ __ ] Lakers Celtics
documentary thing that they got on ESPN
so I have to check that out but before I
do that before I do then a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up the goddamn podcast that
podcast I [ __ ] up the password ain't
no complex these things have to be now
you know and you know you know I hate
when you [ __ ] put a nice easy one in
and then they just say to you like I
yeah that's not a that's not good enough
that's not [ __ ] good enough it's like
well why don't I determine that why are
you acting like I'm in the Pentagon I
don't give a [ __ ] you know what I mean
oh you know what's hilarious too now
that I got a I'm out of my bonham phase
I still play do some Zeppelin today I'm
not go lighting when I was over there
but somebody showed me his [ __ ]
remember that car and the song remains
the same that crazy-looking I don't know
who made it forward or some [ __ ] that he
had that held like crazy paintings and
stuff like that you know you always
wonder what happened to that [ __ ] if
somebody bought it and then somebody
else bought it and now it's up for sale
it's like two hundred and fifty [ __ ]
grand you know was going to buy that
thing I'm Jim Irsay of the Colts I think
that guy's going to end up having like
the equivalent of Jay Leno's car
collection he's going to have that with
musical artifacts I mean the guys
getting to the point where he can kind
of [ __ ] with the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame
he's got like a prince guitar he's got
Jerry Garcia's guitar if you had John
Bonham's car that really adds to the
collection then you put your [ __ ]
Prince's guitars and all this Charlie
parker's saxophone whatever the [ __ ]
else that guy owns in the back yeah some
hookers come over he starts doing blow
whatever the [ __ ] it is he doesn't mean
could be a good time no anyways let's
let's read some advertising here upside
down boy turn me alright upside there's
a better way round and round you're
turning me member that one that's a
little obscure Tina you stink the upside
down you turn me it doesn't upside
there's a better way for you to buy
business travel it's called upside every
time you buy a trip that upside you'll
save your company a ton of money and
they give you an amazon gift card worth
hundreds of dollars upsides able to do
this because they bundle your flights
and hotel together for one low price
bundle saving bundled prices saves money
but what the how do I still get a gift
card worth hundreds of dollars
I mean you begin a bundle and it's going
to save money I'm going to come out
around three hundred dollars then you're
going to give me two hundred back this
is like the greatest [ __ ] deal ever
if you're a frequent business traveler
your company saves a ton of money and
you could get thousands a year in gifts
cards just for buying your air and hotel
together upside plus you still get all
your miles if you're shopping for
business travel travel you'd be crazy
not to check out upside comm oh I get
this is going to be buying like business
tickets so what it is business class it
takes just three minutes to see how much
you can save by buying your flights and
hotel together for one low price and
right now when you use my name Barbie
you are are you're guaranteed to get at
least $100 M is a $100 Amazon gift card
for your first trip it probably depends
on how much the ticket is I would guess
that's my name Barbie you are are to get
at least a $100 Amazon gift card for
free save big on travel and get a big
gift card every trip I love upside calm
evidently even though I've never used it
upside calm minimum purchase required
see site for complete details I should
start [ __ ] using that but then
identity you know you give me an Amazon
card and then I got to go on buy [ __ ]
I'm trying to
[ __ ] out of my [ __ ] house I know I
did I read gift it I'll give it to
somebody else say you go you buy [ __ ]
you drown in your own [ __ ] artifacts
whatever the hell he does you buy it
black tux everybody black tux there's
only so many opportunities and lifes to
wear a tuxedo so when your big day or
special event what are the days you know
get married go to a prom you somehow
know the mayor and he's [ __ ] got
something going on you know what else
would you wear you're on trial
it'd be [ __ ] hilarious wear a tuxedo
it's like you're showing respect and
saying you're a little crazy soon if
they convict you can be like hey the
guy's out of his [ __ ] mind who is a
tuxedo where's the doctor you know the
rule bro
there's so many operate when you when
you're big big special event comes rolls
around this spring or summer look just
as great as you feel with suits from
black tux calm with high quality rental
suits and tuxedos delivered to your
doorstep the black tux gives you a new
way to rent plus with their free home
try on you can see the fit and feel the
quality of your suit months before your
event and the best part is it's
completely done online the blue tux calm
lets you create your look and choose
from tons of styles stylists selected
outfit suits like these usually retail
retail for $1,200 but at the black tux
they start at just $95 if you have any
questions or issues man which you issue
min they're expert customer care team
has your back every step of the way
after ordering your suit will arrive 14
days before your event why do I blow off
commas after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event period
if anything else if anything is less
than perfect the black tux Bulls the
black tux will send you a free
replacement right away when your events
over just drop your rental back in the
mail please wad it up in the [ __ ] box
shipping is free both ways how easy is
that
and out at your event just thinking of
all the stains on the tuxedo have a
[ __ ] hazmat suit on dude if you have
a tuxedo at some point then that your
dicks coming out that's just the fact
stand out at your event for the right
reason with the black D black tux to get
$20 off your purchase visit V black tux
calm / / that's the black tux calm /
bird for $20 off your purchase two more
reads guys hang in there hang the [ __ ]
in there I'm as bored with my reading as
you are LegalZoom in order to
successfully run your business attention
to detail is so critical one contract
slip-up ah Jesus or legal
misunderstanding I didn't do it can
really set you back fortunately there's
legal zone zoom yeah you may already
know that over a million Americans have
used Legal Zoom to start their business
but Legal Zoom services go well beyond
business formation they built a
nationwide network of independent
attorneys who can provide legal answers
to day-to-day questions you have a bunch
of business because let's face it
things like trademarks employment laws
and lease agreements can get pretty
complicated that's such a nice way of
saying you're too scatterbrained to want
to deal with this [ __ ] let us handle it
so don't waste your valuable time trying
to wrap your head around all the fine
print use Legal Zoom for that so they
can focus so you can focus on growing
your business instead you get the legal
help you need without being built by the
hour since Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
abdominus of that sentence get legal
advice from [ __ ] place that isn't a
law firm go to legalzoom.com today and
be sure to enter the enter code bar in
the referral box for special savings
only at legalzoom.com lastly but not
leastly Dollar Shave Club dude Dollar
Shave Club is the smarter choice you'll
get your great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
Dilla you no longer have to schlep to
this stool to buy a cheap disposable
razor that gives you a cheap shave or
spent a fortune on razors with gimmicky
shaving technology you don't [ __ ] need
all right when you use your Dollar Shave
club's executive razor with it it can be
ZZ yeah the blade gently glides across
your balls giving you a smooth [ __ ] on
your face
dr. Carver shea butter is transparent
for the more prices precise shave helps
present ingrown hairs and fights razor
bumps there you go they handle all the
way to white to black people era make
the smart choice by joining Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time new members can
get their first month of the executive
razor with a tube of it dr. Carver's
easy shave really five dollars with free
shipping after that raises it just a few
bucks a month that's a 15 dollar value
for only 5 bucks there are no hidden
fees and no commitments cancel anytime
you like you can only get this offer
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / birth thank
[ __ ] christ that's over over all
right so anyways I'm really [ __ ]
overextended myself this month I said
yes to way too much [ __ ] and for July my
answer is going to be nope I don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody asked me No hey
Billy no I'm not doing it I'm not
[ __ ] doing it I got I'm on the road
again chica boom boom boom I'm doing the
roast of David Ortiz this week Thursday
and I'm you know I got to figure out I
don't do that a I'm not saying this guy
Wacka Wacka but this buh-buh-buh-buh
yada yada yada
you know those [ __ ] roast jokes for
some reason the format of roast jokes is
still from like the 1950s I don't
understand why that is I have to figure
out how to do this [ __ ] so it's always
here you know last time I saw
like that it had a bucket bag away go
well you know they still use that except
the young guys now they all say AIDS and
[ __ ] in [ __ ] just it's just so over
the top
you know 9/11 it's always like I got to
figure out how the [ __ ] to do this and I
only have four days to do it and of
course I'm busy as [ __ ] so I don't know
what to do here so but this is the last
thing if I just get past this which I
will either by doing a good job a
mediocre job or eating my [ __ ] balls
on it the bottom line is it's over you
know it's a 12-minute spot I just have
to get if I get past this [ __ ] roast
the rest of I'm gonna the rest of my
year it's downhill Billy no fun is
saying no to everything what do you what
is it now I can't make it nope can't do
it nah I don't know what it'd be like
that [ __ ] Buzzard way back off
thoughtful people thought bubble
remember that bashful Buzzard on Bugs
Bunny no Hulk Malka do it that's going
to be me I have to start [ __ ] doing
that because yeah it's not good it's
just too much [ __ ] and I am I'm again
now with the kid I'm [ __ ] I'm
exhausted it's 9:22 at night and I was
ready for bed two [ __ ] hours ago it's
just my cutie pie doesn't fall asleep
till about 9:00 and you know what's
great about no booze you sleep like a
[ __ ] baby
I mean booze will put you to sleep but
the next morning you wake up and you
just like you know what you wake up you
feel you should be tied to a chair you
know and there's some guy just waiting
for you to come around to continue
interrogating you by punching you in the
head and then you realize like now I
punched myself in the head with all
those [ __ ] drinks so I'm actually
really enjoying it despite the fact I
drank the last two nights I have one
tonight and half of it spilt on the
[ __ ] ground all right
[ __ ] judge me alright I decide I'm in
my own a a okay I still learned a chip
today that's it I just feel like for me
having my own a a is a good thing
speaking of her in reality show stars
you're not going to [ __ ] believe who
I think was at that car show today we're
walking around with looking at David's
[ __ ] this 2-door Cadillac that I
swear to god was like it was like - Town
Cars put together
incredible [ __ ] car gigantic oh my
god I saw this one jag well you know the
one had the early that one in that had
in the 60s with the long [ __ ] hood
not the one from the 50s that Sinatra
had that one the James Bond era one you
know the one
and like the hatchback opened like a
[ __ ] regular door
this guy showing it off right at the
back door opening in the hood opens like
the reverse way you know from the
windshield out looks cool as [ __ ] and
then I look in there he's got like some
small bunch small-block Chevy engine in
this you know I don't know that's what
you want to [ __ ] do I don't know why
you would do that anyways I - walking
around looking at those cars and all of
a sudden me is there's these people on
like you know giving out awards to cars
and [ __ ] and this means listening this
person on the microphone going
I think that's Caitlyn Jenner I think
Caitlyn Jenner she and I was like no
[ __ ] way I got to go seek I got to go
see Kate I gotta go see Wayne by the
time we got there I'm not even sheriff
alike
Nia said that Bruce it gets confusing
he's she said she's really into cars so
I got confused saying like I was was he
not into it and then can that happen do
your hobbies change then I knew what she
was saying it's like no he was into him
he's always been into him and now he's
become Caitlin tried Dyson wants it
transferred
what's the [ __ ] word you're supposed
to say transitioned helicopter November
one five three Sierra Hotel on with you
information Bravo requesting pumpkin
transition through transitioned to you
know being Caitlyn but the hobbies stay
the same there you go who wouldn't know
that I would think you take up some
other hobbies right maybe you wouldn't I
can look this up I gotta look this up
this is [ __ ] weird because I know you
take hormones and stuff right so does
that make it end other [ __ ] it's it's
fine it's fascinating you know and you
know it's funny is they going to keep
doing the same way they do in the
plastic surgery well you know it's going
to keep looking better and better and
better you know I mean same way you know
everything keeps getting better and
better and better except for the [ __ ]
environment you know oh by the way I did
a [ __ ] benefit the other night and
flea was in the crowd I can't [ __ ]
believe I didn't give him a shout-out
for giving a [ __ ] about bees there was
one of the few positive things I saw
about the environment last year was that
flea somehow got it hell fleas up the
[ __ ] bees are dying off and flea
shows up like a goddamn hero and it he
gets into this beekeeping stuff he's got
the whole suit and everything I saw this
whole article on it and he's hooking up
like a little like there was like ten
thousand of them hanging out in his
backyard you know you know what's funny
is that's one of those things your
neighbors would be annoyed at because
they don't understand photosynthesis I
don't know where that [ __ ] word came
from but I literally I think I I think I
used it correctly isn't that when the
bees go from flower to flower and stuff
gets on their cute little feet you know
a cute little bee feet you don't to me
and then they pollinate [ __ ]
inadvertently they're out there running
errands for the Queen right the queen
bee
the [ __ ] was I talking about oh I got a
look this [ __ ] up when you transition do
your hobbies change [ __ ] list am I
going to get put on looking this [ __ ] up
oh come on man don't do this to me come
on Internet come on Internet can you
[ __ ] work for once in your life you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you believe someone who can't even get
internet in his whole house is talking
about having a chauffeur I mean how
[ __ ] first world country is that
habit change is easy when people move
into your house for strategies to change
your habits is that not specific enough
this has to be I have to be wrong you
transition to a woman do your hobbies
change 13 ways to master the transition
from college to the real world habit
changes easier how to successfully
transition your diet nerd Fitness health
in your 40s la you know what I searched
it twice I guess so Bruce was into it
now Bruce is Caitlyn Caitlyn's like you
know good on you Bruce way to get those
[ __ ] cars because I'm still digging
them that's [ __ ] amazing you know I
hope someone I know [ __ ] transitions
let's want to see that whole goddamn
thing you know something's got it
something it's got to be something right
does your preference a color change be
taking hormones like you're [ __ ] with
like the chemicals right is it it
[ __ ] amazing how I just refuse to
read about [ __ ] and I just continue to
ask questions while answering them this
is how I come to conclusions and then I
can somehow legally get on stage with
the microphone or do a [ __ ] podcast I
can't imagine how many people who used
to be men and are now women are just
slapping their female forehead their
transition forehead right now listening
to me as I'm talking about pologize
to anybody out there transitioning I
don't [ __ ] why would I think that
because she said she's really into cars
doesn't take a lot to trip me up that's
all I'm saying alright let's read some
[ __ ] here right mute math and Colbert
hey Billy boom back but we'll go back
thanks for putting me on to mute math oh
my god they're [ __ ] amazing [ __ ]
incredible band they got a brand new
album out whatever you kids say they got
some brand new [ __ ] that you can
download through the [ __ ] air capture
it on your device share it with your
friends man
this guy says I've seen the name before
but never listened and they are all caps
[ __ ] dope just bought a ticket to see
them on their tour in September dude you
are not going to be disappointed they
are [ __ ] as good as their band their
albums are they a [ __ ] incredible
life [ __ ] incredible bin and then he
said to me told me to check out these
bands and says check out big data and
Portugal I don't understand this next
sentence it says the man , I think you
might dig them is the man also a band
I'll look it up alright if my internet
hasn't shut down after that last stupid
[ __ ] search keep drumming and make
Steven keep drumming and making Stephen
Colbert uncomfortable oh I did the
Stephen Colbert show last Thursday aired
Friday I wasn't making him uncomfortable
he enjoyed it
I had a great time with him he's a I met
him briefly one time at some benefit but
uh he's a really good dude it was
[ __ ] amazing to go back and do that
show because that's where Letterman used
to tape and it still [ __ ] ice cold in
there it's still roughly like the same
setup and it's just weird because
Colbert's desk is over where the band is
and I talked to him you know during the
break like a loyal guy was as crazy
being over here you know I did stand-up
on Letterman like four or five times and
this is where I always look over and
Felicia and Paul Shaffer Anton Fagel the
whole band was over there
and now the desk is here and he said
that he asked Letterman where he should
put the desk and let him instead on the
right side saying that he always wanted
to sit over there but Johnny sat over
there so out of respect he sat on the
other side that's how much you know the
level of respect I was amazed amazing
story the level of respect that
Letterman had for Carson and why
wouldn't you the guy's the king of it
all but Letterman was the Carson of my
generation all right
Phelps versus the shark bill I just
listened to your Monday morning your
Thursday afternoon just before Monday
podcast and enjoyed your rant about the
upcoming fight between McGregor and
Mayweather it's not it wasn't a rant was
it a rant I just was discussing the
[ __ ] subject I was screaming and
yelling ranting and raving that is a
[ __ ] read you know I'm going to look
up rants that probably would run wrong
about you know if you transition your
[ __ ] habits change why the [ __ ] would
I be wrong about this rant definition
come on
Oh somehow I go to rant now what the
[ __ ] is that now rant you can't come on
definition ok rant definition speak or
shout at length in a wild impassioned
way yeah she was still ranting on the I
don't know what I think this just goes
back to me being from Massachusetts and
my ideas of yelling and [ __ ] being
out of control are just different than
everybody else's but you're going to say
I ranted finally fine whatever um yeah I
just you know I [ __ ] hate most about
that MacGregor Mayweather fight aside
from the fact that that McGregor is only
going to be allowed to box me that guy's
a [ __ ] Swiss Army knife of death and
they're only let him take out the spoon
you know you want [ __ ] annoys the
[ __ ] out of me about that fighters I
know I'm going to order it I know I'm
been ordering how do you lay off that
once I found out it's only going to be
I thought it would be like 200 bucks I
thought they'll both make it a hundred
million
I guess Mayweather makes 100 million
McGregor makes 20 million for whatever
[ __ ] reason how [ __ ] up is that
I think the guy that isn't you know if
they were doing the fact that McGregor
isn't allowed to do what the [ __ ] you
know we could do which is put Mayweather
right on his back and the thing would be
over in 30 [ __ ] seconds he should be
getting 100 million this is a walk in
the park for Mayweather this is his
[ __ ] strength never went the other
way
McGregor was allowed to use all of his
[ __ ] fighting skills than Mayweather
she get the hundred million this is
classic Mayweather this guy's a [ __ ]
genius he's getting it entirely his way
and he's making 80 million dollars more
than this other [ __ ] guy anyways he
goes did you see that Michael Phelps is
going to race a great white shark for
some Discovery Channel thing I [ __ ]
refused that's a joke right that has to
be a joke do I have to look this up I
thought you might like that one that's
that that is [ __ ] ridiculous I'm
alright I got a look at him would do
even if the shark was full I mean that's
this is like the Mayweather [ __ ]
McGregor fight this is what he does mean
Phelps swims but he also does other [ __ ]
he goes to restaurants you know what I
mean he hits a bong every once in a
while what the [ __ ] is a shark do that's
all it does there's no [ __ ] way
there's no self oh my god it ain't no
Phelps first shark this can't be [ __ ]
real Michael Phelps to race a great to
race against a great white shark in
shark weeks
Phelps first shark Jesus whatever
happens just being on the [ __ ] weeds
Buck's not making enough money doing
that Michael Phelps hasn't done swimming
yet the 23 time Oh 23 time Olympic gold
medals this guy is 23 gold but you know
what this guy wants to racist you know
yet course he does he's done with human
beings I think a shark is a good tune-up
fight when you're going into the ocean I
think - I don't know who put this
together maybe it was Mayweather he
saying he always picks the perfect
[ __ ] opponent you go in there against
a great white shark you know to me
they're they're not known for this speed
are they
so he's dolphin zipping around it's
always the [ __ ] that they have to
[ __ ] catch that's fast right then the
slowest thing gets caught by 23 time
Olympic gold medallist will compete in
the most adrenaline-filled race yet when
he swims against a great white shark for
this Discovery Channel Shark Week
alright so how do i handicap this are
they starting in the water is the shark
got to get up on that [ __ ] block -
and wait for the whistle ah we got a
false start we got a false start we're
having difficulty explain to the shark
what the [ __ ] of whistle is he's just so
freaked out that he's out of his natural
atmosphere here in Phelps first shark
great gold verse great white is what
they're calling this the retired athlete
will take on the oceans most efficient
predator in a competition of speed Jesus
Christ can you imagine who is Nike
putting up to swim goggles for the
[ __ ] shark alright I guess Phelps
tweeted something I was able to do
something that I'd always wanted to do
being a cage and dive with great white
sharks um wait is he Mary's got a kid
now go to him first birthday party hey
happy Father's Day to him what kind of a
dad he's got it you know what he's got
all that gold you know you know it's
finding the dollar the entire US economy
could collapse and he's going to be fine
he's got 23 gold medals he just melt
those [ __ ] thing down you make little
nickel size coins that guys eaten subs
for the rest of his [ __ ] life
Phelps great white race isn't the only
Shark Week special he'll be appearing in
the father of one will also join I'll
give a [ __ ] about the what he's doing I
together the trio will dispel myths and
misconceptions and teach Phelps the
proper way to get up close and personal
with hammerheads and great whites okay
you know it's funny about [ __ ] the
Discovery Channel after all these years
of being the champions the absolute
champions of misinformation about sharks
you always watch their things on the
sharks you'd always watch these things
on the sharks and while you watch the
program they'd always say all this you
know these things are being hunted down
there are misunderstood blah blah blah
but when you watch the [ __ ]
advertising for that week Shark Week it
was always they was like another jaws
movie was coming out it was really bad
so now I guess they're finally feeling
guilty and maybe some younger people
came in on the Discovery Channel they
finally done I don't know [ __ ] on
sharks
so wait was the way they being a [ __ ]
saltwater pool if they're in a pool I
liked Phelps for the simple fact that I
have a feeling that the Sharks going to
go out of its Lane and be disqualified
and at the very least the shark can't do
that little somersault flip at the end
of the [ __ ] pool Jesus Christ exists
this is what the world is the world of
sport is becoming I don't know back in
the day used to have those [ __ ] fat
bald guys strongmen
they were always bald right someone
lifting weights back in the day you know
you went bald
and they would always be pulling trains
with their teeth and [ __ ]
all right first time listening hey Bill
first time let's think to your podcast
my husband and I came to LA for the Rose
Bowl last year and saw you stand up we
loved it thank you thanks for taking so
much thanks so much for take talking in
detail about jazz and sports I think
this show this think this shows a lot of
respect for your audience we like cool
[ __ ] obviously we like to stand up don't
be afraid to go into technical details
about whatever it's interesting anywho
happy podcasting well alright there's
two people that are enjoying it I think
I talked about it a little bit I
downloaded all of his [ __ ] Miles
Davis [ __ ] I am like I was a huge
Miles Davis fan like in the early 90s
and my favorite album was in a silent
way and I read his autobiography I got
like [ __ ] I mean I had all this [ __ ]
on like his set tapes
I even got like on the corner which he
talks about in his book how when Herbie
Hancock came out with chameleon like
that's what he was trying to do that
head on his album but you know he blamed
the record label saying that they know
they [ __ ] up the promotion of it but I
got into all of that [ __ ] and then I
moved to New York I stopped playing
drums because you know I was living in a
walkthrough [ __ ] bedroom apartment and
it just comes in too goddamn loud I
didn't play for like five six years and
then I started back up again so I I
started in 88 and I've been I would like
a five-year break in that so I've been
playing about 19 years I don't what the
[ __ ] it is but anyways Dave Brubeck jazz
stuff here we go more drum [ __ ] dear
Billy backbeat not the exact error you
were asking for but Dave Brubeck's band
experimented with some crazy time
signatures starting in the early 60s
look for the album the Dave Brubeck
Quartet at Carnegie Hall I bought it
when I was a music major in college and
it was a borderline spiritual experience
it's got songs and 11:4 aptly named
eleven for wait a minute eleven for now
how the [ __ ] does that work out eleven
for so you just count that's when you
count that just up to eleven alright so
that's just basically it's like playing
three three bars of four and then you
just play one bar three four and you
just lop off that last beat right five
four take five
nine eight blue Rondo alla turca not
only the song is great but the audio
quality is impressive for the time
period every once in a while you can
even hear Dave or another member of the
band
blurt out a cool jazzy yeah during a
solo it really immerses you in the time
period and culture all right you know
this is a classic I'm going to download
this and listen this with some really
nice headphones in the dark and probably
wish that I you know did some drugs if
you listen to a check out the track
Castilian drums at the 4-minute mark
there's a drum solo where he turns the
snare off and does some really cool and
creative stuff with his hands and it
sticks on the snare
if you look at Joe Morello [ __ ] where
he's playing with his hands and stuff
and then watched John Bonham playing
with his [ __ ] hands I'm sure he
Morello wasn't the first he only got to
do it but there's just a couple things
where he's hitting with the back of his
hand and [ __ ] you see Bonham do that but
then there's also like like YouTube and
all that [ __ ] did not exist when Bonham
was coming up so he was over in England
the odds of him checking that out and
actually seeing it is it's so [ __ ] I
don't know how people were able to you
definitely listen to everything you
could but to actually get to watch all
of them he was [ __ ] and so when
something came on the TV you just
[ __ ] sat there and watched it
there was no hit and pause there's no
all there's going to be a rerun and if
you missed it you [ __ ] missed it
anyways this guy says thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself with that shiny new high
headstand Jesus Christ all right joining
the army Haney if you want to come in
there's a question for you yeah grab a
grab a mic bring in the tyke and grab a
mic bringing in the tyke and grab a mic
lalala get your ass in here and do the
podcast Baba where are you so you're
coming it's hot as hell in here I don't
open a window I don't know
okay can you uh can you there's a
microphone over there can you in the
closeted area
oh Jesus she's uh she's a cutie well I
can't do a podcast Hannah look kid at
the same time Jesus Christ one of my
multitasking hey buddy
ma mic up on top of the [ __ ] thing
there on top of the thing straight ahead
she's got it please don't tip over my
computer don't tip it over um all right
this is perilous err I'm holding her and
there's a computer here she's going to
knock it over and she's going to knock
it over what's up cutie pie what's up
cutie
all right plug it in there plug it in
plug it in and here we go ladies and
gentlemen coming back to the podcast I
don't need to put the screen you don't
he put a windscreen on any of the window
open can you grab your beautiful
daughter here please please I know I
know I know I know
all right here's a question for you how
did you pull the map up all right here's
your question
all right you ready dancing wedding okay
hey there Billy back freckle my
girlfriend and myself are attending a
wedding for our good friends two gay
fellas this is a very progressive
podcast by the way that you're doing yes
because I already brought up Caitlyn
Jenner and I learned something today
when you kind of freaked me out when you
said like oh she's really into cars why
did that freak you out then because I
know I had to do the math of my head was
like was Bruce not into cars so then I
was like no wait I've ever read the
Sports Illustrated Porsches and he was a
pilot and all that [ __ ] right mm-hmm
does his pilot's license they must
transfer over do you got to change the
name how crazy is that then you got to
go down there be like listen I'm this
guy now I'm I'm sure it's everyone knows
they're Caitlyn Jenner is right all
right so if you're not our thing but if
you're not famous
yeah you're not famous you probably got
to do who got them yeah I'm gonna do but
I am I'm gonna you know I'm gonna get
you for Mother's Day next year they
speaking into a my class sorry all right
so here it is by the way so I googled it
when you transition to you habits change
and nothing came up so I guess it
doesn't
okay what's the Connie one thinks one
little thing would be kind of like oh
[ __ ] now I'm into this have you taken
like hormones and stuff like when
something change your favorite color
would change I don't think so it doesn't
affect your brain oh right why don't you
allow to ask questions about this [ __ ]
is it me like oh my god what are you a
[ __ ] trump supporter I'm really
excited to go to this wedding he's
saying okay you guys are getting married
right to gate fellas as he says I'm
really excited to go - the fact that
they are dancing fools could they be
more stereotypical my girl and that
whole group will be dancing the night
away well so wedding yeah do you not
want to do this no I'm just trying to I
could wait to hear the question fully
please proceed okay you seem annoyed at
any point you need to walk out I'm fine
with it okay he says me for me he says
me for me for me I just feel he says me
I'm not a dancer
perhaps I shouldn't assume but I'm
assuming that you're no dancer yourself
evidently he has not seen daddy's home
right I'm the worst
I'm your standard pasty white guy who
doesn't really dance I don't like it I
don't really understand it it's just you
don't understand just seems goofy to me
I totally line up with this guy I
haven't appreciates it for yeah you
dance at the wedding though
you've answered our wedding all night
long I was drunk my girlfriend has
expressed her dislike with my opinion of
dancing after a couple of drinks going
as far as to tell me it's a real
disappointment but I don't enjoy dancing
oh I love how honest she is you know
it's a real disappointment in our four
years together of you but I'm
really dis really disappointed and I
completely don't respect the fact you
don't like something I like hey Nia do
you like hockey
uh oh no what I do
could you just play along no I doubt a
real disappointment home in our four
years together we've never really had
any sort of arguments other than that
one Jesus Christ if the only thing you
argue about home you're very lucky how
often do you guys go marrying this girl
he goes I don't try and guilt her into
doing something she doesn't like so I
get a little hot-blooded when she does
it to me hot blooded
can't you see if we'd answer to that one
half light it was it I got a guy in a
row of a hundred and three come on
babies do you do all their dance right
that's another white guy doesn't want to
dance they do more to dance can we get
out of here mm-hmm
so we get a yeah invent herpes uh well
what do you think what do you think old
Ruby pupae Ruby PU they I don't stand my
ground and what if do I stand my ground
and what will most definitely become a
disagreement when I don't go flail
around like the non dancing whitey that
I am or do i sack up and do my best
revolted from pulp fiction and go
attempt to cut some rug even though I'll
be miserable the whole time best to you
your little one and and season two of
efforts of family has been great thanks
for the content and go after yourself
all right all right all right so what
are you saying well as I'm doctor we
said earlier it's a wedding so obviously
there's going to be dancing whether
they're gay guys or straight like
everybody dances at weddings but not I
don't know how he expected like why
would he think that there wouldn't be
dancing maybe that's not they had
nothing to do with the gigas you just
say he doesn't want it he just doesn't
want to dance no why can't dance
okay oh they saying about me see the way
that I walk oh I don't know listen girls
I like to dance like guys that like to
dance with them that's just how it is
that's the name of a new reality show if
you don't go in there and do the YMCA
and the electric slide you can at least
do a couple of slow dances how about
that
can you call hi meet me outside how
about that guy's nose catch me like that
maybe that can be the compromise listen
I'm not going to go up there YMCA and
celebrate good stuff Carlos doo-doo-doo
this is not a carrier what's going on
guys I don't know I'm saying so none of
those things with a beloved Prince you
know do we have Prince on our wedding I
don't stay focused oh yes
I think the compromise sir is that you
should give your lady a couple of slow
dances and also also wait a minute it's
one night it's not going to kill you to
get up there and like be goofy with her
no one's watching you because I feel
like there's a little bit of you that's
like you don't like to dance because you
feel like you can't dance nobody's
looking at you nobody's judging you
it's one night out of your life just be
silly have fun with it and definitely
slow dance with her she'll really
appreciate this is one of those times
where even though you don't like doing
something you do it for the person that
you love this is what is it my
suggestion but you're not going out
dancing every single Saturday would you
put with a wedding you should I'm a
little distracted so I'm sorry I can't
put my mouth like you know want me to
blow the damn microphone no I can do you
hello oh that's not a
I'm thinking ethanol hypercar that okay
I'll do that
Thank You Paloma singer I just what he
should do you should go go there and
have five quick drinks five five get
[ __ ] hammered and then just go out
there and then just that's it
you blackout drunk I don't think that'll
be getting walk around like a fish out
of water
yeah and the next day I don't agree yeah
hungover and you're laying there and
she's giving you look you just look at
her and your best Clint Eastwood voice
and you just feel like it was your idea
[Music]
you want me to dance these are the rules
that would just tell us it listen I'm
going to dance my ass off that night
okay
and I want you to know how stupid I'm
going to feel I'm doing this for you
however these are the rules
you line up five shots I'm doing those
it's like mr. blonde going through that
Bank
bad bad bad bad bad if you had made me
go out on the [ __ ] dance floor I
don't think you should get a good mr.
blonde that was alright I don't think
you should be five shots wasted all
right thank you [ __ ] would you accept
three I would take two and see how it
goes oh you're the worst three given
three this is a major anxiety
Nia think of all the stuff you don't
like to do right exactly yeah but I'm
just saying and well how about this can
you at least give us how are ya before
he gets wasted can you just give her a
slug because we love slow dances they
don't start with the slow dance I know
you go out there and it's like
immediately like maybe we get down on it
yeah get down on it
do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do the baby with it I'm just
burnin doin the neutron dance
someone stole my brand-new Chevrolet
yeah at that point you gotta be like I'd
be like [ __ ] you gotta be put you
gotta be five shots in it's one night
out of your life do it because you love
her just as a night this is my dancing
for the year getting on Mon
I gotta be shit-faced did you select a
guy get drunk Mia I don't say this a lot
I don't say this what is the white thing
what do you mean we don't do we don't
dance the white people dance all the
time Fred Astaire we to do it
professionally we just don't do it
either one of those people on Dancing
with the Stars that's it I don't know
all right here's another one fake girl
at jiu-jitsu hey Billy bollocks
so my dilemma is I'm 18 and I'm like
it's a hot is frigging hell can I enter
the a/c on because what am I suppose
I'll hit pause hang on
alright I'm back here we go so my
dilemma is I'm 18 and I just finished
the first my first year of college a few
months ago and I've been hitting the gym
good for you as much as possible good
for you and I've been going to jiu-jitsu
you're crushing it for the past couple
of months anyway first day going there I
noticed a girl in the beginners class
with me
and thought she was hot and she's doing
jujitsu this is cool this is nothing but
great stuff so far so after a couple of
weeks I work up the nerve to talk to
work good for you turns out I went to
school with the younger brother
something in common
this is like all rainbows right now and
I was also the youngest in my year so I
think she might be 19 or 20 Jesus Christ
this is just all aces uh why is my
computer screen keep shut now I don't
know anyway after train I don't know
anyway after training yesterday I asked
her I asked for her snapchat is that the
way Millennials asked for digits no I
never even said digits I'd be like
what's your number did I call you
you like my G cavalry cheese Daisy
Buchanan's dude it's a meat market try
not to curse in front of her even though
he's already done it 50 times here I
don't know what any I don't know anyway
it's a trip of and she gave it to me and
after I asked her for it
I felt like a weight had been lifted
because I've never really talked to that
many girls let alone get their snapchat
whatever is good hey long because I'm
incredibly reluctant and a bit scared to
talk to them yeah pathetic I know but I
think this girl is girlfriend material
that's not pathetic not just a [ __ ] one
time [ __ ]
that was pathetic yeah he really just
made a left turn there that statement
was pathetic he kind of built himself up
as the aw shucks guy yeah and then he
found it around and said how he's a
Ladykiller yeah well I know what it is
what he's afraid of love
whatever no no G what you just did you
just turned her off alright I think I'm
solo on this one
so Billy Boy what should I do how should
I go about this how should I text her
any advice would be appreciated
love the podcast wouldn't mind hearing
for the lovely Mia's input - if possible
would love for you to just let a guy be
a guy would ya that's the equivalent of
you guys mean like what does he do for a
livin how much does he make do what size
house could I get when I kick him out is
that the equivalent bill yes equivalent
equivalent as well nobody talks like
that at least on myself oh sorry
oh my god for me I feel I need a twist
however your friends stuff would love
for you not like play a gig in Ireland
sometime thanks - go F yourself - I play
again I played three last year I went
from Dublin up to Belfast and out to
Galway and an isosceles triangle of
freckled fuckos I performed two out
there are you trying to be a badass with
this whole not a one time [ __ ] [ __ ]
type of thing like what was that what
was that a little statement he threw in
there because that did really turn me
off why do you keep latching on to that
this guy has all kinds of great
qualities 18 he's he's one year into
college okay he's hitting the gym he's
taking jujitsu he saw a beautiful woman
he was smitten by her and he's nervous
okay he was teased it's locker-room talk
I didn't don't understand why he just
don't hold the Olga wall around why he
has to be like categorizing girls that
he doesn't even know and so this is like
the
a bit you just [ __ ] once and this is
girlfriend material go [ __ ] yourself how
much you're not going to get laid and
you're an [ __ ] that won't have a
girlfriend how about that how does that
feel
Mimi I'm sad how about that it catches
me outside about that yeah yeah you guys
do the same thing we're not talking
about what you guys do and what
everybody else does I'm talking about
this person that wrote in this question
okay that's not that's not what this
conversation is about you know what
everyone in a Giles I want her to feel
my passion okay no oh her
I'm not we are we're not discussing what
women do versus what men do we're
talking about this particular person who
is like oh good for you you got her nap
chat also like snapchat grow a pair and
get her number if you're really trying
to like come with it like don't be
lurking on her snapchat so you can like
jerk off to her like little selfie pics
I mean no way with this person I'm sorry
I just you know what I'm jealous of this
person you know what fun I don't either
he's working out into the gel a pretty
that little line that you threw in so
I'm married in it why should he feel
Iike no type away about it so um alright
his wife here's my advice was what do
you know something I Mia I swear to God
if you were a pitcher right now I'm
coming out and before I even get to the
mound of taking you out of the game and
even out I mean it means you get way too
emotional you lost your control and
you're gonna kill somebody it's a shower
now she's girlfriend material not just a
one-time you know [ __ ] you [ __ ] one
this guy cannot run in from the bullpen
quick enough you've completely lost your
composure hit the showers on this one
alright how do you know what kind of
person she is
oh boy because you decided because you
projected what you want your fantasy
because she's got a real person to you
right she's not a real person
she's just someone you saw doing jujitsu
and it's like oh my god this is like my
dream girl not like those other girl
that you just like toss to the side you
don't even know her
you even care to know her you got our
snapshot her snapshot really blow a pair
ask for the number or stay the [ __ ] away
don't be lurking online like some kind
of creep what is the first exam it was
from Ireland Colin Mia Phil Seamus
Seamus only Eddie no Sheamus
this guy has no Sheamus sorry Patrick
listen yes um don't you hate didn't you
guys have like oh this guy's husband
material
yes well alright then so why don't you
relax all right
good lord I do that I really got hot you
got grumpy all right fine yes this is
there are definitely guys that you're
like this guy you would not want to be
in relationship this is a guy that you
just like bang out a few times and don't
ever see again
yes that were you mean for bang out a
few times no I right you're right women
do the same thing it's a hundred percent
true I just took 20 minutes to get there
I don't know just bug me
of course it bugged me but I'm being a
hypocrite because I've certainly had
those feelings of toward certain guys so
exactly it's about time I [ __ ]
admitting that instead of acting like
the world ojio rounded drinks here's a
man he's found he's smitten with this
girl
he's afraid get out home so he just knew
your toots coming in there huh yes well
this is what I would say how should you
go about this you can have to do
something that's probably difficult at
your age and I hate when older people
say this but you got to figure out a way
to beat yourself yes got a walker i
you've said enough to you no I think
you've said it I'm sorry Shane I'm sorry
I held that year ago I think you've said
enough here
I think you dumped a whole bunch of
other stuff from other days was it
something I did I don't know but this
guy did not deserve that this is an 18
year old he just became a man okay okay
I overreacted a little bit he's a
colleague going to college he's gonna
wanna defend his family bank Fogarty's
right with his jiu-jitsu I'm just saying
if you were my son I'd be like and
you're not can you get off it Nia all
right I'm off it yeah you're a hypocrite
during hypocrite but what I love about
you come as you admit what a pig you are
what the rest of us Jesus Christ did he
give the kid some advice here what was
the question he got a snapchat oh he's
nervous
he actually likes this woman what is he
doing she just be himself just listen I
got a mitt like he I I saw you across
the room I had a man was a little mini
heart attack I really like you I'd like
to take you out but yeah you got to go
on a stay just ask yeah you don't have
to sit there and brood in the corner
it's ready there's no reason to see you
what you do is you you fake with those
ones you're just going to bang somebody
actually like you got to be honest with
the Moroso it's not going to work so
just yeah okay this is getting real over
there I go okay cool ah I think you
again I think you both need a nap time
so yeah I know I'm sorry about that
all right hey we all get whatever his
name is yeah well you know his name is
Vinny um
all right okay dancing at the wedding I
already did that girl of jiu-jitsu
I already did that did I answer all the
questions oh joining the army joining
the army as you can sail the seven seas
in the army you can eat some mushy peas
in the army I'll get joining the army
there William no fun I'll skip all the
ass kissing since you blow through all
your bow through on your reads anyway
all right I'm a 34 year old married guy
former Navy vet buh-ba-ba-bah who's sick
of feeling like a [ __ ] I want to do
something with my life and feel like
making a difference I've kicked around
the idea of going
back into the military for a while now
and it shit-or-get-off-the-pot time wow
you wanna go back into the military 34
okay I brought this up to my wife in the
past and all she can say is you're
married and changes the subject some
backstory on us we've been together for
seven years and married five ish we've
had our ups and downs like any couple
but I get sick of being treated like a
child when it comes to my own life
anyway I'm just about at the cutoff age
cutoff age wise to go down the path I
want in life I want to be a combat medic
Jesus Christ oh good lord man I mean how
much excitement do you need in your life
you already served and you want to go
back here this guy's a friggin hero here
said I'm a determined man who cares
about my family and my family and my
country I've done my research and I have
the time to join do the medic training
go to rasp Ranger assessment program
you're going to become an Army Ranger at
34 do you guys ever watch that
documentary on Netflix about just to see
if you're worthy of going through like
the week-long of ten days of 14 days a
hell only thing I remember was they had
this giant like telephone pole that you
and ten of the guys had to hold up and
do curls with it or some [ __ ] and his
people quit the rest of you had to hold
the thing up I mean I was screaming in
pain watching it and if you puke in the
pit you had to get your puke out of the
pit it was just like it just that
beginning thing was more obstacles than
I've ever faced in my entire life you
are a driven man you're a special kind
of person man if you think that's
Special Forces right he says then
Special Operations combat medic training
my question is bill what do I do here do
I risk losing her or stay here and
resent her I don't want to do either but
I also can't continue to work myself to
death as a
struction worker making someone else
rich at the cost of my health and
happiness dude if you want to be a
combat medic in your [ __ ] putting
drywall in I mean that's got to be
torturing you
he said I've worked seven twelve to six
months six seven days a week 12 hours a
day for six goddamn months trying to
save money to go to nursing school she
tells me she booked us on a cruise she
spent that money on a cruise leave oh
boy I don't know what to do and I need
your help thanks in advance for your
advice and thanks for the medic mediocre
job uh nepotism family go [ __ ] yourself
by his appeal dude what's going on your
relationship is a critical lack of
communication okay you're telling her
what you want to do she's just saying
you're married changes the subject you
saved up all that money to go to nursing
school and either she didn't realize
that that was what it was for and booked
you on a cruise or she's one of the most
selfish people on the planet which I
don't think you would have brought that
up so I think what's going on here is
you're one of these you're this guy's
guy John Wayne type and like most of
them you know people like that you ask
you how you're doing and you just say
fine all right what you need to do is
you got to open up you got to sit down
you gotta say listen we got to talk and
you have to sit down and tell her what
you want to do tell her how you feel at
work and you have to communicate and
start there and work your way to the
Ranger assessment program that's what
you have to do because other than that
you have a major blowout argument on the
horizon and her catchphrase is going to
be where is all of this coming from you
know you if you're one of those guys
that does stuff the right way there's a
problem
you can run into where you have this
expectation that everybody else should
also do things the right way and when
they don't then you get [ __ ] pissed
and it's it's all of it builds of this
complete like I lead by example in all
that [ __ ] you got to learn how to
communicate so yeah I would sit down
with there and I would talk to her all
right and good luck with that those are
amazing frigging goals I just want to
learn how to play Tommy the cat that's
what I want to do anyways that's the
podcast everybody I hope you enjoyed it
by the way I have I have a number of
friends on that show I'm dying up here
and they're telling me that as good as
the pilot was it just keeps getting
better and better and better and there's
a zillion shows out there so they really
need people to watch the book was
[ __ ] incredible I know Jim Carrey's
names attached to it so I know it's
going to be great I'm going to watch
episode 2 right now al Madrigal the
great al Madrigal who I you know do the
all things comedy podcast network with
and is just a friend in general he's
killing it on there I don't I hope you
guys watch the show cuz I'm really uh I
really I'm really enjoying it I'm a
joined a family babies alright so what
am I going to do here is there anything
else I need to [ __ ] - anything else
that I need to hype here should I give a
shout-out to anything I already gave a
shout-out to flee for saving the bees I
wonder if enough people [ __ ] did that
you know I still can't believe that I
pulled photosynthesis out of my ish I
don't know where I came up with that one
alright that's it everybody check out
I'm dying up here
and I'll check in on you on on uh what
is it Thursday is that what it is
is that what it is Oh Andrew Santino's
on it here we go Eric Griffin I'm going
to get everybody John Daly [ __ ] Ali
Arius um who else who else scroll and
Rick Overton Rick Overton met him back
in the day speaking of neutron dance was
actually in Beverly Hills cup da my rare
is [ __ ] hilarious on it I'm gonna
watch that right now that's what I'm
doing after I upload this podcast our
everybody I hope you have all the dads
out there had a wonderful Father's Day
was incredible day for me to finally get
texts and tweets from people which mean
happy Father's Day meant a lot to me
thank you so much that is it I will
check in on check out audience there we
go that's how you say it on Thursday
alright bye-bye